Democrats are panicking like never
before over new swing state polls
showing Joe Biden getting demolished by
Donald Trump the former president you
like that huh the former president is
making huge inroads with key groups and
carried Biden to the White House a
democratic congresswoman getting
confronted over why black voters are
losing faith in Biden but all she could
do was insult their
intelligence their feelings are
dictating their reality their reality is
that they said that they feel better or
they felt better when Trump was in
office but we've been trying to push
back we've got some very popular
African-American artists that are out
here saying things like oh I got checks
when Trump was in office I want those
checks again we also have an issue as it
relates to Civics in this country and
people not understanding exactly how any
of this works and Morning Joe is having
a new meltdown over Biden's bad poll
numbers he thinks the problem is that're
they're not going after Trump hard
enough whoever inside the White House is
telling Joe Biden not to attack Donald
Trump stop it stop seriously stop it all
right and maybe start a lawn service
with push lawnmowers because you don't
know what you're doing you don't know
what you're talking about and you're
costing the
president all right Harold how
condescending is it for an
africanamerican congresswoman to say
that black Americans are basically too
dumb to understand Civics and reality I
think any politician um uh that is
condescending when they say those things
that the irony here is obviously more
more obvious and politically delicious
to talk about this is black voters are
like every other voter a crime is on the
minds of black voters uh inflation and
the lack of buying power diminished
buying power is on the are on the minds
of of every voter including black voters
what's happening at our border uh and
how you think about your future and your
kids education these are the basics in
politics uh the the young congresswoman
I hope she reflects on what she said
because I think she's entirely wrong and
she should be hopeful that her her own
constituents didn't View and hear what
she said because they may have second
thoughts about her ability to represent
them if you believe that black voters
somehow another are wrong because they
want more money that some they're wrong
because they want safer neighborhoods
somehow they're wrong because they want
their kids to go to good schools
politicians at their best meet voters
where they are and they all go to better
places politicians at their worse and
there's a long line of them who tell
voters that they're doing better than
they think that they're healthier than
they think and they're safer than they
think a lot of them are at home right
now you know um and just to follow up on
that Jesse is she says that I think Joe
Scaro is right though Joe's right right
thanks we'll we'll file that their
reality is that they felt better when
Trump was in office I mean even she
recognizes that that African-Americans I
mean they they had less unemployment
ever uh than in the history of this
country and also Trump has 22% of the
black vote so far according to that poll
you right according to the poll New York
Times poll I I think we should be
treating voters the way I treat women
which is I don't tell them what they're
feeling is
wrong good answer
also I don't like when people speak on
behalf of their own race that's why I
don't speak on behalf of white people
you
don't I thought you were going to say
okay but in the interest of equity
Harolds uh with respect uh and humility
permission to speak on behalf of all
black Americans absolutely
1% I didn't think you were going to say
yes I have nothing prepared all right in
that case Harold I would say you're
right for the first time there is no
difference between blacks and whites
especially when it comes to the
economy gas still costs the same when
you fill it up no matter what color you
are true a Big Mac meal is $18 now no
matter what kind of race you are that
buys it true it's still impossible to
buy a house because rates are at 8%
doesn't matter what race you are true so
as she said black people and white
people liked that free money that we got
during the pandemic it's the same thing
so I don't think she should say those
things and and comes to Trump Greg
you're going to love this he's like a
contractor with a horrible attitude
comes into your house place probably
smells like smoke rude to everybody at
the house his car probably runs over
your grass a little bit but you know
what judge he remodels the kitchen like
a genius your wife is thrilled it looks
spectacular Joe Biden comes in late and
over budget and that's why people don't
like him can't get results
you know Joe Biden Greg proves I mean
Joe Scarboro proves what we've been
saying all along that it's about keeping
Trump out of office and not bettering
the lives of Americans you can tell that
they were worried because you saw in
that clip ma was double fisting you see
that she was like look at that she got
her mug and her other cup there she's
like yeah God knows what's going on over
there look do blacks not understand
biomics yes I don't understand biomics
no one understands biomics including Joe
Biden he doesn't understand it either
Joe Biden's true biomics are personal
biomics right his is getting money from
foreign company countries and getting it
to him if only you could expand that
idea to the rest of us that would really
be generous but there's one set of
Economics for him and another set for us
I would ask blacks were you better off
four years ago of course you were which
raises the question was all the
hyperbole over identity politics and
white supremacy merely deception tools
to convince blacks that the Dems were
their only Ally that you couldn't trust
the other party because they were racist
and it's the Republicans who will be who
will victimize you not the Democrats who
tell you that you're constantly
oppressed so they keep you in their
pocket it's one way to keep the races at
each other's throat so you don't see how
bad the libs have been treating you all
right Dana the best question for you if
he's in if Joe Biden's numbers are so
bad right now and we're a year out um
what does he have to do well they will
say the fundamentals of their race are
strong and that the economy is going to
get better and that people are going to
realize that bomic and the
infrastructure Bill are really what
matters to this country and in fact what
did he do yesterday he could have done
you know a president can do anything any
day that he wants and he chose to do an
event yesterday with Amtrak and
announcing they were getting $25 billion
so for B I think it was billion yeah um
and again like in the previous block
this is not complicated rents too high
jobs aren't plentiful the hard to get a
mortgage difficult on the school front
in terms of getting school choice
although it's getting better in some
places and I think of Guy Benson Guy
Benson was yeah and speaking for Black
America Guy Benson but Guy Benson was on
the Pino on politics podcast after the
debate in Milwaukee he took a uber to
the airport and his driver was a black
woman who wanted to talk about politics
she saw his um credentials and said were
you at the debate want to talk about it
and she said look I I'm paraphrasing but
basically she said I'm a black woman in
Wiscon Milwaukee I'm a Democrat she said
but I could understand why many people
in my family will not want to vote for
him next year because we're all working
two jobs we're all more stressed than we
were and nothing is better for us today
than it was when Biden took office great
that's stress producer ice plunge I
recommend it to black women white women
everybody I'm never doing that never no
never not in the winter time coming
leave that with you leave hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not not get it
anywhere
else